das ist in Ordnung okay vielen Dank
perfekt tschüss okay es geht auch und es ist
sensationell klick zoom hab de die Online-
Talkshow aus Deutschland startet jetzt
mit englischen Interviews mein Name ist
Gustav großspurig ich bin die Gastgeberin von
Opfertochter User fantastisch in meiner Talkshow
und auf diesem einzigartigen kanal hast du auch die
einmalige chance,
meinen prominenten gästen und meinem ersten
englischsprachigen gast deine fragen zu stellen erraten sie unsere serviette ihr
kennt sie vom eurovision song
contest zwei jungs aus norwegen hatten keine
außergewöhnliche performance wesir
flashmob special und der song  Sie
traten bei dieser besonderen Flashmob-
Szene auf. Glow klettert jetzt in die Charts
in Europa, also haben Sie jetzt die Möglichkeit
, Ihre Frage in den Kommentaren zu stellen. Deutsch
und Englisch ist beides erlaubt, aber
hängen Sie besser das Video an und mit etwas
Glück wird netqin antworten  Ihre Frage, also
abonnieren Sie und bleiben
Sie dran